corona virus has been spreading over the
last few weeks and is taking a deadly
form till now 2062 cases has been
confirmed inside China and 56 were dead
out of them even outside China there are
are 54 confirmed cases in Canada
Australia and France at this moment we
should ask that how deadly this virus is
okay let us first compare this virus
with some other viral outbreaks such as
avian flu Ebola SARS and Mars all of
these numbers shows percent mortality in
case of Ebola or avian flu there was
quite a lot of mortality but till now
the Enco 2019 the corona virus of novel
strain has only killed four percent of
the infected persons that means how
deadly it is it does not look so deadly
should we worry at this point of time we
should ask that if there any treatment
is there any reaction or does our body
fight back against the virus what is the
situation
it turns out the World Health
Organization has pointed out the risk
factor could be very high even though
the mortality reported so far is low and
only 4% but the risk factor is high
because many of the cases there are
individuals who are infected but not yet
dead so the mortality might increase so
but it also not true that if you are
infected by this virus you would always
die because our immune system would try
to protect our body from this kind of
virus attack right but the biggest
problem is let's say you are an infected
person and you sneeze or cough in public
and later on some other people go from
the same route these viruses are
actually present in the aerosols and
when you breed that aerosol it enters
your lung and it can
affect you so this is the big problem
that means if you are infected knowingly
or unknowingly if you do sneezing
coughing etc in public there are ninety
percent chance that the some of the
people in the public would be affected
by this virus so it can spread
dramatically as it is airborne now the
biggest problem is there are many people
who are infected but not showing any
kind of symptoms it is deadly because if
you are not showing any symptom you
might not report your case to the
hospital and that's how the government
might not know about it
but people who are infected might be
very more than estimated so this is the
big problem and also them in when when
the more mortality is concerned at this
particular point of time the virus might
not be able to kill all of the people
who are infected but in future the
number may vary that is why this virus
is spotted out to be a high-risk virus
now you should wear specific masks but
not the mask you wear for to avoid the
pollutions these masks would only
protect you some from some big particle
and there is a particle cart off so
these are not the recommended masks well
they're the recommended masks is in 95
viral protection masks which would
prevent a virus to go out or new virus
or aerosol driven virus to come in right
will protect yourselves
but n95 mask has another problem with in
95 mask the gaseous exchange is very low
and limited so it can be a problem for
people having breathing problem already
so it is only way by which you can
prevent yourself from getting
contamination from the air now let's
look at how corona virus affect our
lungs inside our lung there are small
sacs these are known as alveoli these
are al filled sacs and outside of that
there is a contact of blood
now these blood vessels are actually
getting the oxygen which we breathe in
in our lungs and these oxygen is
distributed all over our body so this
gaseous exchange that is taking place in
the alveoli is super-important but in
case of corona virus infection our lung
gets severe inflammation now this
inflammation is a good thing in terms of
protection our body would try to protect
by alarming the immune system but at the
same time few damaging incident would
also happen in our lungs our Airways
would be clocked by thick mucus and it
would be hard to breathe and it would be
problem for gaseous exchange moreover
many dead cells dead immune cells and
fluid would be accumulated in the
alveoli and this would be totally filled
up with pus and it would hinder the
process of gaseous exchange when the
virus enters and infect one lung cell
there are mechanisms inside our body
which involves cytotoxic killer t-cell
to kill that viral infected cell but the
problem is once the cell is infected by
the virus nearby cells can also get
infected by that particular virus
because virus grows rapidly inside a
host cell and makes it makes itself
ready to prepare other cells in the
vicinity but the cell which is infected
is pretty intelligent every human being
would produce something called
interferon interferon an alarming signal
which tailed a nearby cell that
something is wrong in this cell now this
particular cell has no option to leave
it will die
but it would send an alarm to its
neighbor its neighboring cell would
undergo specific signal transduction
pathway which ultimately produce
antiviral molecule which would interfere
with viral reproduction process or viral
assembly processes and thereby this
particular cell which is present in the
near vicinity with the help of
interferon can get immune or get
action against these virus infection so
don't think your body is just like a
sitting duck your body is trying to
fight back against these viruses and
many of the cases the body wins and that
is why hundred percent of the cases you
don't see a mortality the mortality is
only four percent yet so your body is
fighting back but you might also ask
that if body is fighting back then why
there even four percent dip now it
depends upon the viral titer you don't
know how you are getting the infection
or what type of aerosol you have prepped
now this aerosol might have a huge load
of virus or might have a low load of
virus so the viral titer inside your
lung is very important if the viral
titer is so high our body's immune
system would fail to protect it and then
comes the danger but in case of low
titer our body can really fight back
against this virus and there is a chance
for recovery so the best thing that we
can do is take rest keep ourselves in
isolation such that we don't spread this
infection and while we are infected and
our immune system is trying to fight in
this sensitive period we should not get
exposed to other pathogens it would
create the situation even more
complicated now Chinese government has
really made a lot of effort to create
these isolation chambers inside the
hospital which would prevent the spread
of these viruses and specially the
Chinese medical team has done incredible
job to prevent the virus spread if you
like this video please please share this
video among your friends and people you
know in order to grow ever less and if
you like this video hit that thumbs up
button and don't forget to like share
and subscribe thank you